Tradutor: Maurício Kakuei Tanaka
Revisor: Leonardo Silva
Quando eu conto para as pessoas
que eu sou skatista profissional,
a primeira coisa que acontece
é que elas não acreditam,
e a segunda coisa é que, em 90%
dos casos, as pessoas falam:
"Ah, eu já tentei andar
de skate, mas eu caí".
Quantos de vocês aqui já tentaram
andar de skate e caíram alguma vez?
Praticamente todo mundo.
Vou contar pra vocês o que aconteceu
quando tentei subir em cima do skate.
Eu caí e me machuquei feio
e, algum tempo depois de ter me curado,
conseguido tirar o gesso da perna,
eu fui lá e subi de novo.
E continuei andando.
Aí, depois de algum tempo, eu participei
do meu primeiro campeonato.
E eu fiquei em antepenúltimo,
nunca foi em último, foi antepenúltimo.
Isso despertou em mim o sentimento
de: "Eu não posso ser tão ruim assim!"
Porque, no dia a dia, ando bem,
mas, na hora do campeonato,
fiquei lá pra última.
Preciso fazer alguma coisa pra mudar.
Preciso fazer alguma coisa pra melhorar.
E aí, a primeira lição
que eu aprendi com o skate foi:
você vai cair.
Você vai cair o tempo inteiro.
Você vai cair mais do que
você vai ficar de pé.
E é por isso que aprender a cair
é mais importante do que aprender
a andar, aprender a ficar de pé.
E a segunda coisa que você precisa
saber é o que te motiva a levantar,
porque, pra levantar, você
precisa ter uma motivação.
E você tem que levantar
rápido pra tentar de novo.
Esse é um gráfico meio imaginário
dos dias em que eu ando de skate.
Num dia em que eu estou tranquila
e vou sem foco profissional,
eu passo 50% do tempo descansando,
31% acertando e 18% caindo.
Agora, num dia em que eu vou tentar
alguma manobra desafiadora,
eu passo 89% caindo,
10% descansando e 1% acertando.
Esse 1% é equivalente a 5 segundos.
Nas outras três horas
em que eu estou andando,
eu simplesmente estou
cometendo erro atrás de erro.
E, juntando essas duas coisas,
que são os dias de zona de conforto
e os dias em que você
se puxa um pouco mais...
porque as coisas costumam acontecer
quando a gente sai
da nossa zona de conforto...
é que gera a evolução.
E esse é o meu motivo pra continuar.
É buscar a evolução:
é ser melhor amanhã do que eu fui ontem,
mas sem perder o foco no presente,
curtindo o meu momento
e não pensando no que já aconteceu
ou no que está para acontecer.
Eu acho que a minha melhor manobra
é a que está sempre por vir.
Eu nunca me conformo com o que eu já fiz.
Eu sempre busco o novo,
e acho que eu consigo me superar
a cada dia e a cada vez que eu ando.
Isso faz com que eu seja uma pessoa
aberta para novas oportunidades,
pra aprender com os meus próprios erros,
buscar novos conhecimentos
e estar aberta a pessoas
que tenham alguma coisa pra me ensinar
ou a situações que tenham alguma coisa
pra me ensinar também.
Acho que isso é
uma característica em comum
das pessoas que são bem-sucedidas.
No momento de campeonato,
acontece um fato peculiar:
de repente, você para de escutar música,
você para de enxergar as pessoas
que estão à sua volta,
e só o que importa
é o que você tem pra fazer.
E é uma coisa que eu não
conseguiria explicar pra vocês.
É uma coisa que tem que ser sentida.
Ser mulher, num esporte
predominantemente masculino,
podia ser uma limitação,
mas acabou sendo minha maior força,
porque eu sempre tive certeza de que
o que eu estava fazendo era bom é certo.
Ser o primeiro em qualquer
coisa que vocês façam
é explorar um território que não tem mapa.
Você não sabe o que vai acontecer depois.
É desafiador, mas não é
impossível; não é impossível.
Ele só nunca foi feito antes,
mas alguém tem que ir lá e fazer.
E vale a pena porque depois você percebe
o quanto isso inspira outras pessoas
que vêm atrás de você
a fazerem o mesmo.
Outra pergunta que sempre me fazem
é se eu sofri preconceito,
se o preconceito existe.
O preconceito existe, é óbvio.
Só que eu percebi que o tempo inteiro
eu estava distraída demais,
focada nas manobras que eu ia aprender
ou nos campeonatos que eu queria ganhar,
pra dar atenção pra ele.
Então, de alguma forma,
ele me perseguia, e eu ia dando "olé",
lidando com ferramentas
que eu julgava serem as melhores,
porque eu percebi que a mudança
não é racional, ela é política.
Então, eu sempre tentei lidar
com inteligência, em vez de força,
e a resposta pra essas pessoas veio
não em forma de palavras,
mas em forma de acontecimentos.
O skate, de 2009 pra 2015,
passou de 4 milhões de praticantes
pra 8,5 milhões de praticantes,
sendo que 19% são meninas.
(Aplausos)
As pessoas me perguntam também
se eu não tenho medo.
É óbvio que eu tenho medo;
eu não sou louca.
Só que eu não fico pensando no medo.
Toda vez que eu "dropo"
ou que eu coloco meu skate no pé,
eu não penso que vou cair de cara.
Eu penso que eu vou ficar
em cima, que eu vou acertar.
Me perguntam também se eu tenho vergonha.
Eu tinha muita vergonha.
Só que eu percebi que as pessoas também
estavam ocupadas fazendo as coisas delas,
e elas não estavam olhando tanto pra mim
quanto eu pensava que elas estavam.
A gente tem mania de pensar que
a gente é o centro do universo, não é?
Mas não é.
Eu acho que eu aprendi com cada erro.
Todas as vezes que eu caí, eu percebi
que eu estava mais perto do acerto.
Cada vez que eu errava,
eu sabia o que eu tinha que não fazer.
E eu entendia qual era o caminho
pra eu chegar ao meu objetivo.
Ou seja, eu concluí que a minha próxima
manobra, a minha melhor manobra,
ela vai chegar.
É só uma questão de tempo e persistência.
Acabou.
(Risos)
(Aplausos)